- [Voiceover] When for the
first time the United States
imported more oil than it exported,
Americans should have realized
than an energy crisis was imminent
and could happen in the future.
So this was a little strange,
because if you're saying that
something is or was imminent,
so imminent means it's about to happen,
and you're fairly sure
it's going to happen.
You have a high degree of confidence
that something is about to happen.
Then you're saying this is imminent.
You're pretty much sure
it's about to happen.
So they're saying it was imminent,
but then they say, and
could happen in the future.
Well if you're saying
something is imminent,
then you shouldn't have
the uncertainty of,
well, maybe it happens in the future,
maybe it could happen in the future.
This seems a little
bit contradictory here.
So I don't like it as it's written.
You're either imminent or it
could happen in the future.
So let's think about other options.
I actually would have
liked this a lot more
if it literally just said was imminent,
or if it just said,
an energy crisis could
happen in the future,
if it just said that one.
So, I don't like having
both of them there.
So let's think about the other options.
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
could happen imminently in the future.
So this feels a little bit clumsy.
At least it doesn't have kind
of the weird contradiction
of something both being
imminent and maybe happening.
So, I don't know, but it still
feels a little bit clumsy.
Could happen imminently in the future.
And actually this is not contradictory,
but this one's a little bit redundant.
Imminently means it's about
to happen in the future,
and then they say, in the future.
Well you don't have to write in the future
if you wrote imminently.
Something's about to happen imminently,
it's not going to happen in
the present or in the past.
It's about to happen in the future.
So you wouldn't put in the
future right over there.
So I would actually rule
this one out as well.
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
will be imminent and happening soon.
Well, this is very redundant, just like B.
If something is imminent,
that's the same thing
as it's happening soon.
You don't have to say, and happening soon.
So let's rule that one out.
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
is an imminent thing.
And here it's actually
more of the verb tense
that I'm a little concerned about.
Americans should have.
We're talking about something in the past.
Americans should have realized.
This was the first time the United States
imported more oil than it exported.
This happened in the past.
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
was an imminent thing.
So this, I would have put a was in there,
and maybe I would have felt
a little bit more comfortable with it.
So I'll rule that out.
So we're left with one.
Let's hope this one works.
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
might be imminent.
That one feels right.
It might be imminent.
We aren't sure whether
something is imminent.
You can't say that it will be
imminent and you're not sure,
but you could be unsure of
is the thing going to happen soon.
So this one actually feels really good.
Let me read the whole thing.
When for the first time the United States
imported more oil than it exported,
Americans should have
realized that an energy crisis
might be imminent.
Yeah, nice and clean.
Nice and simple.
Not redundant.
Feels good.